the i-team's david charns is live
outside of the legislature in the state
capitol with a preview of what we can
expect
over the next few months and days david
well good evening sasha things get
kicking off here at about 11 o'clock
tomorrow morning of course kovitt is
changing the way
business is done this year families and
friends of lawmakers will not be allowed
in the building
and the building is restricted to
lawmakers and staff
everyone can only watch and weigh in
virtually now if you're unfamiliar
the legislative session is when
lawmakers meet for four months to vote
on a budget and make new laws
they have a lot to get to as well first
and foremost how to balance the state's
nearly nine
billion dollar budget amid a pandemic
that's devastated our economy
democrats and republicans will have to
come together finding ways to get
nevadans vaccinated
and back to work they'll also be
focusing on funding our schools health
care including medicaid
and what to do with money our state
received from the federal government
now we talked to leadership on both
sides earlier this month about what
conversations could look like
we already made uh some tough decisions
and cut our state budget by 30
um and that's uh a state budget that was
already one of the most lean in the
country
so uh we're going to have to you know
live within our means
and deal with the uh further budgets you
know restraints
i think you're going to see a
continuation
of a lot of those cuts due
you know due to the revenue shortfall
from you know the governor's closures
now one thing we will likely continue to
see is that republican finger pointing
to governor sissellac though he followed
federal guidelines from former president
trump a republican
and of course the cdc republicans may
also try to rein in the governor's
executive power though that would fail
with democrats in power here
republicans did gain seats in november
but democrats do remain in control in
both the senate and the assembly
but they no longer have what's called a
super majority
meaning they will have to make some
compromises this time around
now an interesting note here also in the
majority this
this session are women in both the
senate and the assembly
nevada actually the only state where
that is applicable
and right now on eight newsnow.com we
have some tips for
if you want to weigh in virtually online
of course you won't be able to enter the
building so how will you listen to those
sessions those committee meetings
it's all on right online right now on
eightnewsnow.com
live from a very snowy carson city
tonight i'm david charns 8 news now